merci mes chers collègues la parole est
à Monsieur alain GOURNAC pour une
question monsieur mise à l'intérieur
je suis le président madame la ministre
je voulais vous remercier d'abord d'être
là souhaitais poser ma question à
Monsieur Valls ministre de l'intérieur
parce qu'il y avait déjà eu une
conversation auparavant et vous
accepterez que je regrette qu'il soit
pas là mais je comprends qu'il soit
occupé madame la ministre les faits sont
aujourd'hui un peu anciens mais le
principe qui semble les sous tendres
étant toujours d'actualité d'actualité
il demeure tout autant d'actualité
d'interroger le ministre de l'Intérieur
sur ce que j'appelle les deux poids de
mesure qu'en matière de sécurité
commence de créer un malaise dans notre
pays quelques faits en décembre 2012 les
pickpockets étant toujours plus nombreux
une armée et toujours plus agressif au
Louvre la direction du musée avait
déposé plainte auprès du parquet de
Paris elle avait également demandé des
renforts policiers au 10 avril 2013
aucune mesure sérieuse n'avait été mise
en place pour remédier à ses agissements
qui portent préjudice aux visiteurs pour
beaucoup je dirais la majorité des
étrangers et nuisent à la réputation de
notre pays aussi 200 agents du musée
ont-ils fini par exercer leur droit de
retraite en fait ils sont mis en grève
quelques semaines plus tôt le 20 mars
2013 l'agression d'un groupe de
touristes chinois ronçonné devant un
restaurant au Bourget avec réagir Pékin
confirmant le caractère grave de ces
agissements et l'image déplorables de
notre pays cette grève des agents du
Louvre a eu lieu après la manif pour
tous du 24 mars 2013 au cours de
laquelle des jets de gaz lacrymogènes
furent dirigés contre des familles des
filants pacifiquement j'y étais ça s'est
passé à côté de moi derrière moi
quand le ministre de l'Intérieur a eu
besoin il a su trouver les forces de
l'ordre pour faire taire les opposants
au mariage pour tous mais ce n'était pas
leur rôle c'est tout maintien de l'ordre
républicain pas de l'ordre socialiste
qu'elle doit être employés on évoquant
c'est dévoiement préoccupant et qui
inquiète les Français je ne peux
m'empêcher de penser à ce jeune opposant
au mariage pour tous qui a été
interpellé incarcéré j'étais pas à côté
de lui à Fleury-Mérogis non non son cas
étant examiné aujourd'hui par la cour
d'appel je n'en dirai pas plus parce que
je crois que c'est aujourd'hui le 13 mai
au Trocadéro madame la ministre la
police insuffisante en ont pu empêcher
qu'éclate de violences affrontements
entre supporters de clubs de football et
que le quartier soit mis à sac depuis
elle a remonté les pistes des jeunes
casseurs connus de ses services et
procédés à des arrestations trop tard
trop tard les violences et les dégâts
estimés à un million d'euros avec eu
lieu ma question est simple madame la
ministre elle est double comment les
forces de police sont-elles utilisées
quelles mesures le ministre entend-il
prendre pour que les situations en
matière de sécurité soient mieux
appréhendées c'est-à-dire des bons sens
et sans esprit partisans merci monsieur
mon cher collègue la parole est à Madame
Hélène conduit Mouret mini chargée des
Français d'étrangers
monsieur le sénateur ma réponse sera non
partisane et elle sera celle du ministre
de l'Intérieur qui ne peut être présent
ce matin et qui s'en excuse la lutte
contre la délinquance et en particulier
les pics pocket que vous avez fait
référence aux abords du Louvre
constituent l'une des priorités des
effectifs de la préfecture de police
autour du secteur touristique Louvre
Palais-Royal plus de 10000 personnes on
fait l'objet d'un contrôle depuis juin
2012 et plus de 2000 individus ont été
interpellés pour vol simple vol à
l'étalage vente à la sauvette ou
escroquerie à la suite des 140
opérations réalisées depuis le début de
l'année 2013 ces contrôles réalisés sur
la base de réquisition du procureur de
la République ont été maintenus et
récemment renforcés dans le cadre du
plan mis en place depuis le 7 juin pour
accroître la sécurité des zones
touristiques
la présence policière aux abords des
principaux sites parisiens avaient
l'objet d'un renforcement depuis le mois
d'avril dernier ainsi chaque jour plus
de 200 policiers sont mobilisés dans
toute la capitale et dans les réseaux de
transport pour lutter notamment contre
l'effet de délinquance commis à
l'encontre des touristes
au-delà du renforcement de la présence
policière une série de mesures de nature
à renforcer la sécurité des touristes
fréquentant la capitale a été présentée
par le préfet de police ce plan fondé
sur 26 mesures a été définie en
partenariat avec la Ville de Paris les
professionnels du tourisme dont le fils
du tourisme et des Congrès de Paris et
les responsables des sites touristiques
les hôteliers les transporteurs ainsi
que différents ministères
puis l'amélioration de l'accueil des
victimes étrangères en facilitant le
dépôt de plainte dans sa langue
d'origine l'accès au Service de police à
proximité des sites touristiques et la
prise de contact avec des interprètes
enfin quatrième point la meilleure
diffusion de l'information sur la
sécurité à travers une nouvelle édition
d'un guide pratique intitulé Paris en
toute sécurité qui sera traduit en six
langues
ces actions et déjà permis de constater
des résultats significatifs le nombre de
violences volontaires dans les secteurs
touristiques à diminué de 12% par
rapport au mois d'avril 2012 et le
nombre de plaintes pour vol dans
l'enceinte du musée du Louvre et passer
de 120 en moyenne par mois à une
trentaine en mai soit une baisse de 75%.
la direction de l'établissement a
d'ailleurs exprimé publiquement sa
satisfaction et saluer le travail
accompli par les services de police à
l'occasion d'une visite sur site du
préfet de police le 6 juin dernier les
résultats obtenus démontrent pour
répondre directement à votre question
que les forces de police sont déployées
comme il le faut là où il le faut dans
un souci constant d'assurer à nos
concitoyens et à tous ceux qui visitent
la capitale un cadre de vie sûre et
respectueux des droits de chacun
d'abord madame la ministre je vous
remercie moi je vais vous dire j'étais
parce que j'ai pas voulu prendre le
métro j'ai traversé j'étais à
l'Assemblée nationale et j'ai traversé
jusqu'à la Madeleine bah écoutez il y
avait pas un policier vous auriez vu si
le japonais ou
coréen ne s'est pas fait voler devant
moi non alors je veux je suis d'accord
200 policiers C'est vous qui le dites
comment voulez-vous qu'aujourd'hui on
protège l'ensemble des des étrangers et
des pensées aussi aux provinciaux il
s'attaquent aux provinciaux qui savent
pas trop qui laisse des portefeuilles
derrière des sacs ouverts 200 policiers
c'est pas du tout ce qui nous faut et
alors la chose aussi qui m'a intéressée
dans votre réponse c'est protéger
certaines sorties d'hôtel il commence à
s'attaquer autour il savait qu'ils sont
devant qui attendent le bus ou qui
attendent un taxi et ça c'est important
je voudrais saluer le guide
je veux saluer le guide parce que le
guide c'est une très bonne chose étant
donné qu'on leur donnerait dès l'arrivée
alors faut pas non plus faire peur à cet
touriste en disant c'est affreux ce qui
se passe en France mais vous me dites à
la fin de votre de votre réponse donc
merci vous me dites la police est bien
utilisée bah écoutez moi j'en ai eu un
journal du soir qui explique parce que
des syndicats de policiers c'est
syndicats de CRS qui disent tout le
contraire ils disent tout le contraire
ce dans cet article qui est assez long
qui est assez bien fait on s'aperçoit
des choses c'est qu'ils disent c'est une
honte ce qu'on a fait je veux même vous
ajouter parce qu'ils peuvent pas parler
ils ont pas de syndicat mais les
gendarmes parce que j'étais une
manifestation les gendarmes devant moi
m'ont dit qu'ils avaient honte de
l'utilisation je suis je suis officier
de gendarmerie alors vous voyez je
connais un tout petit peu le truc ils
m'ont dit j'ai honte de notre
utilisation pour le mariage pour tous
moi j'y étais j'étais derrière la
banderole des élus bon il y avait
d'autres c'était d'un calme absolu il y
avait des femmes des enfants des gosses
beaucoup de Gottes et petit moi
d'ailleurs je répondais si petit dans
une manifestation mais ça regarde chaque
famille et franchement le déploiement de
la police mais c'était absolument
incroyable madame la ministre je vous
promets absolument incroyable j'ai
rarement vu ça j'ai rarement vu ça même
dans des manifestations et juste après
je sais que c'est pas facile pour vous
mais madame je vous dis la vérité quand
vous je suis rien et je savais qu'il y
aurait des incidents place du Trocadéro
j'ai pas de service de renseignement je
peux vous dire que les voyous c'est fou
écouter vous savez c'est sur tweet ils
s'envoient les messages et il savait
très très bien qu'ils avaient tout cassé
et moi j'ai vu des policiers à cette de
votre cadero se quitter pour se pousser
pour laisser passer les voyous quitte
attaquaient un café enfin des glaces des
glaces d'un café donc Madame franchement
transmettez-le monsieur Valls moi je
veux pas faire de polémique je m'en fous
moi je suis fier de mon pays je veux que
les touristes soient bien accueillis je
vous demande vraiment de lui dire qu'il
faut vraiment bien mesurer l'utilisation
de police pour ne pas avoir des
critiques de ce style dans la presse
voilà mais je vous remercie de votre
réponse merci mon cher collègue